Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna score like 12 12 i doing guys
welcome to Moscow good you see we're
here to work yes
what's happening all right you're here
the reason is we're playing against the
Germans first on FIFA World Cup mode but
also physically we need to dominate them
hello - Mateus is the manager the other
team the England that's in top 4 be
lighted up wouldíve yet maybe I'm good
in yet I can't afford to have my
reputation tarnished by you guys you
didn't once again it we're not here to
lose so we've got to fix up fall in line
and deal with the Germans that's for
stunts let's go get kick
[Music]
youngster trouble
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we are guys
this is where we need to actually focus
in toss your in go secure yeah that's
what I want to hear mr. cheeky sports
I'm missing about a no cheekies in the
name I'm not on the pitch
not today boss mr. cow freezing you
control that whole area patroling in man
you're the man with the skills to pay
the bills
after this killed wood or one and
product you got it from wah and my man
the goalscorer got a she revived about
him one chance one goal that's what I
want to hear from you you I am your end
product
who you gonna play like I'm glad you
asked I hope you've got the balls to
handle the pressure
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]